"Fast X" has a cast full of A-list action
stars, but we nearly got an appearance from
"John Wick" himself.
Here's who Keanu Reeves would have played.
One of the most impressive accomplishments
of the "Fast & Furious" franchise is how it
managed to get some serious acting talent
to appear on-screen.
The most recent entry alone has numerous Oscar
winners among the cast, including Dame Helen
Mirren, Brie Larson, Charlize Theron, and
Rita Moreno.
That's on top of casting rising talent in
Jason Momoa and Daniela Melchior.
However, if things had worked out differently,
another major star could have been on the roster.
Alan Ritchson, who stars as scene-stealer
Aimes in "Fast X," revealed to Entertainment
Weekly that Keanu Reeves was initially courted
to play his part.
Reeves is no stranger to action-adventure
films, being the star of multiple franchises
like "The Matrix" and "John Wick."
Ritchson admitted it was tough to try to fill
those shoes:
"I was working on a movie with Hilary Swank
up in Winnipeg in the freezing cold, and I
got a call that things had shifted in the
plans with Keanu Reeves, which is I think
who was originally intended to play my part.
Tough act to follow."
Reeves may not be joining the "Fast" family
just yet, but it was a great opportunity for Ritchson.
Of course, it wasn't that easy, even without
having to compete with the star of "Point Break."
Ritchson mentioned that there were "timing
issues" that could've necessitated another
recasting of Aimes.
He went on to say,
"Basically the deal was if there's no problems,
we don't shut down for COVID or weather, this
should work, and about two weeks later, we
got news that we were going to get hit with
the biggest blizzard in Winnipeg's history."
The production had to shut down temporarily,
and while Ritchson's "Fast" journey could've
ended before it began, the production team
was able to move things around so that he
could be in the movie.
"Everyone becomes family.
It's like a cult with cars."
However, that wasn't the end of Ritchson's
turmoil, as he recounted a phone call from
"Fast X" producer Jeff Kirschenbaum.
He elaborated,
"I was like, 'Oh, God.
Whatever you've got to say, just say it.
I can take it.
I'm a big boy.'
He goes, 'You're not going to be working with
[director] Justin [Lin] on this.'
I was like, 'Okay ... am I still in the movie?'"
Kirschenbaum then clarified that Justin Lin
was the one who stepped away from the movie,
but Ritchson would still be in it.
After that confusing back-and-forth, everything
was good, and Ritchson is now a proud member
of the "Fast" family.
Meanwhile, Keanu Reeves certainly isn't short
on work, and he's had plenty of near-miss
appearances in franchise history.
For example, he could've been part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in "Captain Marvel"
when he was offered the part of Yon-Rogg,
which ultimately went to Jude Law.
He turned that down so that he could film
"John Wick: Chapter 3 — Parabellum."
And he could've had a very different role
in the "Fast & Furious" franchise had another
opportunity worked out earlier.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
"Fast & Furious Presents: Hobbs & Shaw" director
David Leitch revealed that there were talks
early on for Reeves to play the part of the
Eteon director, who's nameless and faceless
in the film.
However, as production went on, all parties
involved agreed that it just wasn't a good
fit, so Reeves passed.
Still, there will be opportunities in the
future for Reeves to join the "Fast" franchise
if he wants.
"Fast X" kicked off the beginning of the end
for the mainstay franchise, and it's been
confirmed that some spin-offs are in the works,
including one that will be female-led.
It's safe to say that if Reeves really wants
to be part of the "Fast" family, any director
would jump at the chance to get him involved.